today i'm going to tell you why you need
to stop learning new programming
languages
hey help me out with the youtube
algorithm just like and subscribe so i
have to start by saying if you're
learning a programming language because
you like the pursuit of knowledge then
yeah go learn that language but i want
to speak directly to the people who say
like hey i learned ruby and java and
node and i still can't get a job what's
the next language i should learn well
the next language that you learn
shouldn't be a language it should be a
stack and i'm not playing favorites here
it can be the mean stack it can be the
lamp stack it can be the net framework
stack it doesn't matter just learn a
stack here's why most corporate software
involves business process you're
basically taking data and putting it in
a form then taking the data from the
form and putting it into some kind of
process where you do something with that
data then you take that data and put it
in a database then you keep that data in
the database until you need it again and
you read that data out of the database
so what you need to be able to do is do
some front-end work where you can put
data into forms and validate that data
you need to do some middleware where you
take that data from the form and then
you need to do some database work where
you can put that data into a database
and read it back out again now there's
three exceptions to this the first is c
plus plus there's still plenty of
companies that need c plus plus and
they're running native applications
where they need a lot of speed to do
something so if you're just into c plus
that's fine get super into c plus plus
and get really good at it the second is
swift if you're really into making apps
you can learn swift and within a couple
of months a couple of weeks even start
developing apps in swift for the iphone
the third is python which is probably
the most popular programming language in
the world right now but it's not that
good for ui development you can't really
do mobile development with it it's slow
so usually companies are using python
but they're also using another language
to access python so python's a little
iffy once you get out of the ai and
machine learning space my preferred
stack is the dotnet stack uh that
doesn't mean it's better or worse than
any other stack it's just what i like
and i mainly like it because in a lot of
ways c sharp is a trait it's like
learning hairdressing or plumbing or
carpentry you know there's a lot of
small to mid-sized companies out there
that settle on microsoft and net as a
solution and they need people like you
to go in and
fix or add on or maintain their current
business process software which is
probably written in csharp.net
so my best advice to you is that if
you're learning a new programming
language you need to stop that today
see if your knowledge is able to take
information from a form push it across
something and put it into a database and
then retrieve that again if you can't do
that with your current level of
understanding of a language or framework
learn how to do that first now let's go
turn that software code into money